The question isn't, can you go home again? The question is, do you want to? From the day he left the small town he grew up in, David thought he did. He left Allendale, South Carolina for Princeton, then law school.
问题不在于你是否能再回到家乡。问题在于，你还想回去吗？大卫离开他从小长大的小镇那天起，他就以为自己想。他离开南卡罗来纳州的艾伦代尔，去了普林斯顿，然后又去读了法学院。
I really see myself as being a black Matlock or something like that. I mean, I'm into that idea. I'm into the idea of being the lawyer in town.
我真的觉得自己像是个黑人版的马特洛克之类的人物。我是说，我很认同那个想法。我很喜欢成为镇上律师的那个主意。
Just recently, he was offered a job with a country lawyer back home. And so he and his wife have to decide, what are they going to do? She grew up on a farm outside Allendale. They were childhood sweethearts. And deciding where to go, it's the biggest question in their marriage.
就在最近，家乡的一位乡村律师给他提供了一份工作。于是他和妻子不得不决定，他们该怎么办？她在艾伦代尔外面的一个农场长大。他们是青梅竹马。决定去哪里，这是他们婚姻中最大的问题。
I try to conceptualize myself. Could I really live in a community that small? Could I live in a town with two traffic lights? And I could not see it. I could not visualize it. And I think that only a couple of weeks ago, I told David that I could definitely never live in a town like Allendale.
我试着给自己做个构想。我真的能住在那么小的社区里吗？我能住在只有两个红绿灯的镇上吗？我无法想象。我无法在脑海中浮现那个画面。我想大概就在几周前，我告诉大卫，我绝对永远无法住在像艾伦代尔那样的镇上。
That's pretty strong language, Lee.
这话说的够重的，李。
In a sense, their dispute comes down to a difference over how they view a central fact of small town life, that feeling that comes when you know everybody knows you and knows your business. He likes that feeling.
某种程度上，他们的分歧归结于对小镇生活一个核心事实的不同看法，那就是当你觉得每个人都认识你、都知道你的私事时所产生的那种感觉。他喜欢那种感觉。
People knowing your business or wanting to know your business, I mean, it sounds like a horrible thing. But that, whatever, nosiness, in some respects, keeps you in line. People knowing that my car was potentially parked at Letta's house at a time that it shouldn't have been keeps me in line. I mean, so you don't do that. You don't do the things that you know the neighbor next door can report back to your mom. You just have to be a good boy. And that's the way that I see myself in Allendale. I'm Allendale's little, good boy.
人们了解你的私事或者想要打听你的私事，听起来像是件可怕的事。但那种，不管怎么说，窥探欲，在某些方面，会让你循规蹈矩。人们知道我的车在不该出现的时候停在莱塔家门口，这会让我循规蹈矩。我是说，你不会那么做。你不会做那些你知道邻居会向你妈告状的事。你只需要做个乖孩子。这就是我在艾伦代尔看待自己的方式。我是艾伦代尔的小乖孩。
And I think that I always bucked against being a good girl. I mean, don't get me wrong, I was not a mischievous child. I didn't have any discipline problems. But I think that, at a very early age, I was fiercely an individualist. And I think that, when you want to take stake-out, and behave in your own way, and have a personality that may not be assimilated to everyone else's, it's just painful in a small town, because it sticks out.
我觉得我总是反抗去做个乖女孩。别误会，我不是个淘气的孩子。我没有任何纪律问题。但我认为，很小的时候，我就有着强烈的个人主义。我认为，当你想要特立独行，以自己的方式行事，并且拥有一个可能无法同化于他人的个性时，在小镇里是很痛苦的，因为那太显眼了。
Her views on abortion and race relations didn't square with the prevalent opinions in Allendale. The speech she gave as high school valedictorian, a speech critical of the school system, was a minor town scandal. People apparently talked about it for months. And so, for now, they're stuck living in Manhattan, trying to decide if they see small town life as cozy or as claustrophobic.
她对堕胎和种族关系的看法与艾伦代尔普遍的观点不符。她作为高中毕业代表致辞时，批评了学校制度，这在镇上成了一桩小丑闻。人们显然谈论了几个月。所以，目前他们还困在曼哈顿生活，试图决定他们是将小镇生活视为舒适还是压抑。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, Small Towns, the claustrophobia and freedom and yearning for small towns. Act One, Country Mouse, City Mouse, a family moves from a tiny town to the big city, or what seems to them, anyway, like the big city.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是“小镇”，关于小镇的压抑、自由和向往。第一幕，“乡村老鼠，城市老鼠”，一个家庭从一个小镇搬到了大城市，或者至少在他们看来像是大城市的地方。
Act Two, a get-together of single farmers who are trying to get other farmers to stay in rural America by marrying them. Act three-- Three Chicago teenagers make the argument that the public housing project that they live in, a high rise building here in one of the biggest cities in the country, is actually a small town. Stay with us.
第二幕，一群单身农民的聚会，他们试图通过联姻让其他农民留在美国的农村。第三幕，三名芝加哥青少年提出论点，认为他们居住的公共住房项目——这个国家最大的城市之一里的一栋高层建筑——实际上就是一个小镇。请继续收听。
Act one-- City Mouse, Country Mouse. One of the classic American stories is the migration from small town to big city, and all the personal growth, and dangers, and freedom that happen when you make that move. Our contributing editor, Sarah Vowell, went through that change yourself, with her family, but with one small catch. The big city that her family moved to wasn't New York, or Los Angeles, or Boston. It was Bozeman, Montana, population 30,000. Which sounds like a small town to anybody who lives in a city, but it was, in fact, 30 times larger than Braggs, Oklahoma where they started.
第一幕，“城市老鼠，乡村老鼠”。经典的美国故事之一是从小镇向大城市的迁徙，以及当你做出这种改变时所经历的所有个人成长、危险和自由。我们的特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔和她的家人也经历了这种转变，但有一个小插曲。她家人搬去的大城市不是纽约、洛杉矶或波士顿。而是蒙大拿州的博兹曼，人口3万。对于任何住在城市里的人来说，这听起来像个小镇，但实际上，它比他们出发地俄克拉荷马州的布拉格斯大了30倍。
We were hopeful immigrants from small town Oklahoma who set out for a better life in small-town Montana and became new people. Where else but America can an okra-eating, twang-talking, God-fearing, good girl like me be given the opportunity to turn into the liquored-up, opinion-mongering heathen I am today?
我们是从俄克拉荷马州小镇出发，怀揣希望的移民，去蒙大拿州的小镇追求更好的生活，并成为了新人。除了美国，哪里还能让像我这样吃秋葵、说话带乡音、敬畏上帝的乖女孩，有机会变成今天这个喝得烂醉、爱发表意见的异教徒呢？
My twin sister and I were born Okies in Muskogee, because that's where the nearest hospital was. But we lived in Braggs, a dusty little Muskogee county nowhere, home to a 1,000 people, four churches, one school, a couple of stores, and a much vilified bar called The Little Oklahoma.
我和孪生姐姐是“奥基人”（俄克拉荷马人），出生在马斯科吉，因为那是最近的医院所在地。但我们住在布拉格斯，一个多尘的、马斯科吉县的无名小地，有1000人口、四座教堂、一所学校、几家商店，以及一家臭名昭著的酒吧，叫“小俄克拉荷马”。
Our mother took us to Braggs' Pentecostal church three times a week, where I got saved, got baptized, and prayed with her and the others in the ladies prayer meeting for The Little Oklahoma to be shut down. And I sang, sang in church, sang at home, sang along with my transistor radio to the Tulsa country station. I sang for God, because I knew God was listening. When I was six, I got a tape recorder for Christmas. And here's the first song I sang into it.
母亲每周带我们去布拉格斯的五旬节派教堂三次，我在那里得救、受洗，并和她以及其他人在妇女祈祷会上祈祷，希望“小俄克拉荷马”酒吧关门。我唱歌，在教堂唱，在家里唱，跟着我的晶体管收音机唱塔尔萨乡村音乐电台的歌。我为上帝而唱，因为我知道上帝在听。六岁时，我收到了圣诞礼物——一台录音机。这是我录下的第一首歌。
[SINGING] I will be a helper at home, at church, at school. I will be a helper, obeying Bible rules. When there's work for me to do, I'll do it happily. I will be a helper to everyone I see.
[歌唱] 我要做个好帮手，在家里、在教堂、在学校。我要做个好帮手，遵守圣经的规则。当有工作要做时，我会开心地完成。我要成为我所见之人的帮手。
I hate that song more than any other. Every time it pops into my head, I shiver, because it's a spooky reminder of the docile woman I might have become had I stayed in that town, in that church, where there are so many rules and so many eyes upon you. Not to mention the fact that God himself ran the biggest stake-out of them all, and you knew that, come Judgment Day, you'd account for every last slip your preacher and his minions had somehow missed.
我讨厌那首歌胜过任何其他歌。每当它浮现在脑海中，我就会发抖，因为它时刻提醒着我，如果我留在那个镇上，留在那个有很多规矩、有很多双眼睛盯着你的教堂里，我可能会变成一个多么唯唯诺诺的女人。更不用说上帝本人就在进行着最大规模的监视，你知道，等到审判日，你得为你牧师及其爪牙们漏掉的每一个小过失负责。
Small towns are always hotbeds of surveillance, but when you add fundamentalist religion to the mix, the things you can't do outnumber the things you can. Sex is bad. Drinking's bad. Smoking's bad. Women standing up to their husbands is bad. Questioning scripture is bad. Not attending church is bad. Cussing is pretty damn bad. And, as my father would soon find out, moving away is really, really bad.
小镇总是监视的温床，但当加上原教旨主义宗教时，你不能做的事比能做的事还多。性是坏的。喝酒是坏的。抽烟是坏的。女人顶撞丈夫是坏的。质疑圣经是坏的。不去教堂是坏的。咒骂是非常糟糕的。而且，正如我父亲很快会发现的，搬走是非常、非常糟糕的。
If you ask him why we left Braggs and moved to Bozeman-- and believe me, my mother's family has never stopped asking-- he'll launch into this whole song and dance about his health.
如果你问他为什么要离开布拉格斯搬到博兹曼——相信我，我母亲的家人从来没停止过询问——他就会开始长篇大论，把原因归结为他的健康。
One of the main deals was my asthma, health problems.
主要原因之一是我的哮喘，健康问题。
Now, Dad, you've been giving us the old, health line for years.
爸，那种老掉牙的健康理由你都已经说了好几年了。
Yeah, that was one of the reasons for leaving there.
是的，那确实是离开那里的原因之一。
Yeah, what was the real reason?
是啊，真正的原因是什么？
The real reason, I wanted out of there.
真正的原因，我想离开那里。
Why?
为什么？
Go somewhere that was a lot cooler, and--
去个凉快得多的地方，而且——
And any other reasons? I mean, what, specifically--
还有其他原因吗？我是说，具体是什么——
The hunting is real good here.
这里的狩猎条件真的很好。
Dad, you're not answering the question. Tell me what you hated about Oklahoma.
爸，你没回答问题。告诉我你讨厌俄克拉荷马州的什么。
Mainly, kind of the heat in the summertime.
主要是，夏天那种热度。
My dad's being diplomatic. No matter how many times I reassured him that this radio program is not on any stations in Oklahoma, and that no one in our family would listen to it if it were, he still didn't want to come right out and say why he wanted to leave Oklahoma.
我爸在打外交辞令。无论我多少次向他保证这个广播节目在俄克拉荷马州的任何电台都没有播出，而且即便播出，我们家人也不会听，他还是不想直接说出他想离开俄克拉荷马的原因。
It was to get away from family, his and my mother's. They were nosy, and they were everywhere. Every summer, itching to get away from them and Braggs, he'd drive us to the Rockies. Oh, look at the pretty mountains, Mom would say. That Old Faithful sure is something. My mother, my sister, and I just thought we were on vacation. Turns out Dad was scouting out an escape route.
是为了躲开家人，他那边的和母亲那边的。他们太爱打听，而且无处不在。每年夏天，为了逃离他们和布拉格斯，他都会开车带我们去落基山脉。看那美丽的群山，妈妈会说。那“老忠实”喷泉真是名不虚传。我母亲、姐姐和我只是以为我们在度假。原来我爸是在探查逃跑路线。
He still wanted to live in a small town. It's just that he wanted to live in a small town where he didn't know anyone. So he picked Bozeman. It was the right size, surrounded by gorgeous mountains, and best of all, had the vital statistics he was after-- Vowell family, 4, acquaintances 0.
他仍然想住在小镇。只是他想住在一个人都不认识的小镇。所以他选了博兹曼。它大小合适，四周群山环绕，最棒的是，拥有他追求的统计数据——沃威尔家族，4人，熟人，0。
Arriving in Bozeman at the age of 11, I felt like we had just moved to Paris, a town of culture and ideas, of libraries, and movie theaters, and record stores. I still celebrate the first day we got there, June 5, as a birthday of sorts. Bozeman had miles and miles of cement for us to rollerskate around on, instead of the stunted 50-foot strip of sidewalk in our Braggs backyard. My sister Amy remembers pulling into town.
11岁那年到达博兹曼，我觉得我们像是搬到了巴黎，一个充满文化和思想、有图书馆、电影院和唱片店的城镇。我至今仍庆祝我们到达的那天，6月5日，作为某种生日。博兹曼有连绵数英里的水泥地供我们滑旱冰，而不是布拉格斯后院那条发育不良的50英尺长的人行道。我姐姐艾米记得车开进镇子时的情景。
I remember coming over the pass, and we'd been driving through the mountains or whatever, and it seemed really, super huge. It was weird being around so much concrete and just organization. We were just set loose out in the world, too. Where, in Oklahoma, we could wander around, but it was always like in the front pasture, or the back woods, or walk over to our pa's house or something. None of this like, just cruise around a whole town. And it kind of freaked us out.
我记得越过山口，我们一直在山里开车之类的，它看起来真的超级巨大。被这么多混凝土和组织感包围感觉很奇怪。我们就像是被释放到了世界上一样。在俄克拉荷马，我们可以四处闲逛，但总是在前牧场、后树林，或者走到爷爷家之类的。没有那种，在这个城镇里到处乱逛的感觉。那让我们有点惊慌。
But it was exciting, too.
但也挺令人兴奋的。
It was.
是啊。
One of the things I liked about living in Bozeman was that there was a library. Remember in Braggs, the whole school, wasn't it like a shelf with some books on it for 12 grades of people? And Bozeman had separate buildings that were libraries, and how fun that was to just go and look at all the books we wanted.
我在博兹曼住着喜欢的其中一点就是有图书馆。还记得在布拉格斯吗，整个学校，难道不是只有一架子书供12个年级的人用吗？而博兹曼有单独的图书馆大楼，能进去看所有我们想看的书，真是太棒了。
In Bozeman, I thrived, my sister blossomed, my father found his thrill, but the move was hard on my mom. She missed her epic family. The thing that made my father squirm about small town life, being surrounded by people who know you, was exactly what she'd loved about it. Her family is huge and hilarious, with big mouths and bigger hearts.
在博兹曼，我茁壮成长，姐姐灿烂绽放，父亲找到了他的兴奋点，但这搬迁对我妈来说很难。她想念她那庞大的家族。当初让我父亲对小镇生活感到不安的那件事——被认识你的人包围——正是她所热爱的。她的家族庞大又风趣，个个心直口快，却有着更宽广的心胸。
And up north, she missed her fiery, southern-style church. There weren't any other Pentecostals in Bozeman, so we ended up at the most frigid, watered-down, nondenominational Protestant house of worship possible. We were used to this wrathful, angry, Old Testament Creator. And sitting through week after week of God is love got pretty bland. And after a few years, our church visits tapered off, which was fine by me. Mom, on the other hand, had to deal with not only her own loss of spiritual guidance and community, she had to sit by and watch her children losing Christian steam.
在北方，她怀念她那热情的南方风格教堂。博兹曼没有其他五旬节派教徒，所以我们最终去了当地最冷淡、最稀释、无教派的新教礼拜堂。我们习惯了那个愤怒的、旧约时代的造物主。每周坐在那里听着“上帝就是爱”，感觉很平淡。几年后，我们去教堂的次数就减少了，这正合我意。而妈妈，不仅要应对她失去精神指引和社区的痛苦，还得坐在一旁看着她的孩子们失去基督徒的热情。
Well, let's talk about something we generally avoid talking about.
好吧，我们来谈谈一个我们通常会避免谈论的话题。
OK.
好的。
Do you think-- Well, as you know, at some point, I basically lost my faith and never got it back. Is that a regret of yours? Do you think if we had stayed in Oklahoma, I would still be right there by your side at church with you?
你觉得——嗯，如你所知，在某个时候，我基本上失去了信仰，就再也没找回来。这是一个遗憾吗？你觉得如果我们留在俄克拉荷马，我会不会还在教堂里和你站在一起？
That's interesting, Sarah, because I do think about that a lot. I used to just really think, especially when I found out that you had lost your faith, I thought, if we would have stayed in Oklahoma, this wouldn't have happened to Sarah. I feel really guilty and really bad that we moved to Montana, and Sarah has lost this. But over the years, as I've seen you grow up and realize and know what kind of person you are, I'm wondering, even in Oklahoma, would you have began to search in different areas and maybe doubt?
这很有趣，莎拉，因为我确实经常想那个问题。我过去真的觉得，尤其是当我发现你失去了信仰时，我想，如果我们留在俄克拉荷马，莎拉就不会这样了。我们搬到蒙大拿州，莎拉失去了这一切，我感到非常内疚，非常难过。但多年来，看着你长大，了解到你是个什么样的人，我在想，即便在俄克拉荷马，你是否也会开始在不同领域探索，甚至产生怀疑？
Are you calling me a bad seed, Mom?
妈，你是在说我是个坏苗子吗？
No, no. I'm not. No, I'm not. I'm not. I love you very much, and I'm very proud of the person you are, and that's your choice. But it don't keep me from praying every night that you'll return to your faith, Sarah.
不，不。我不是。不，我不是。我非常爱你，我为你成为今天这样的人感到非常骄傲，那是你的选择。但这并不能阻止我每天晚上祈祷你能回归信仰，莎拉。
Amy told me-- I don't remember this-- but Amy said that once, when we were about 13 or so, when we were in Bozeman, you sat us down, and you asked us if we wanted to go back to Braggs. And I would assume the reason for that is, that if we would have said yes, because you obviously wanted to go back, then we would have ganged up on dad or something. Do you remember that?
艾米告诉我——我不记得了——但艾米说，大约我们13岁左右，我们在博兹曼的时候，你曾把我们坐下来，问我们想不想回布拉格斯。我想原因应该是，如果我们答应了，因为你显然想回去，那么我们就会联合起来对付爸爸之类的。你记得吗？
Yes, I do remember that.
是的，我记得。
Were you really? How was it for you when we said we didn't want to go back?
你们当时真的是那么想的吗？当我们说不想回去时，你是什么感觉？
Oh, I was totally devastated. Yes, I remember that very well. I think you were pretty quiet. And it was really neat what Amy said to me. She said, Momma, we understand that you're very unhappy here, and that you miss home, and if you feel that you need to go back, that's OK with Sarah and I. But we want to stay here. And I looked at you, and I said, do you want to stay here, Sarah? And you said, yes, I do.
噢，我当时彻底崩溃了。是的，我记得很清楚。我觉得你当时挺安静的。艾米对我说的话真的很棒。她说，妈妈，我们理解你在那儿很不开心，你想念家乡，如果你觉得你需要回去，我和莎拉没意见。但我们想留在这里。我看着你，说，莎拉，你想留在这里吗？你说，是的，我想。
And so, I mean, I immediately wanted to burst into tears, but I thought, I need to compose myself here. And later that night, as I thought about it, I guess it was a real turning point for me, actually, to start being happy here in Bozeman. Because I thought, OK, I can't leave my children, so I better get it together.
所以，我是说，我当时立刻想大哭一场，但我心想，我得保持冷静。那天晚上晚些时候，当我想到这一点时，我想，那确实是我开始在博兹曼快乐生活的转折点。因为我想，好吧，我不能离开我的孩子们，所以我最好调整好状态。
Because-- and I know you really don't like to hear me say this, Sarah-- because you and Amy have been and are the most important thing in my life. And so there's no way I could have ever gone away and left you.
因为——我知道你真的不喜欢听我这么说，莎拉——因为你和艾米一直是我生命中最重要的人。所以我绝不可能独自离开，留下你们。
There's so much mother-daughter history in the way my Mom says, I know you don't like hearing me say this, because she knows I don't like hearing her say that I'm the most important thing in her life sometimes because of the guilt that involves. And before I started working on this story, I'd always felt badly about the way she sacrificed her happiness for mine. I grew up believing she would've been better off in her little Oklahoma hometown, surrounded by family, embraced by the church. But I found out I was wrong.
我妈说“我知道你不喜欢听我这么说”的方式里，藏着太多的母女过往，因为她知道，有时我不喜欢听她说我依然是她生命中最重要的人，因为这其中包含了负罪感。在开始做这个故事之前，我一直对她为了我牺牲自己的幸福感到愧疚。我长大后一直认为，如果她留在她那个俄克拉荷马的小家乡，被家人包围，被教堂拥抱，她会过得更好。但我发现我错了。
Now, do you still want to go back to Oklahoma?
现在，你还想回俄克拉荷马吗？
Oh, no. No, I could never live in Oklahoma again.
噢，不。不，我再也无法住在俄克拉荷马了。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
I really think that I've changed too much, Sarah. I mean, I love my brothers back there, dearly, and my best friend, Cathy, and there's lots of wonderful people that I just adore and love so much back there, but I do feel that I've changed so much in the 15 years that we've lived here that I could not live in Oklahoma again.
我真的觉得我改变太多了，莎拉。我是说，我深爱着在那里的兄弟们，还有我最好的朋友凯茜，那里有许多我很崇拜、很爱的人，但我真的觉得在这15年的生活里，我改变了太多，以至于我无法再住在俄克拉荷马。
So now, do you think then that Braggs is just too small?
所以现在，你觉得布拉格斯太小了吗？
Yes, I do.
是的。
And when you were growing up there, and when you were living your whole life there, before you moved to Montana, would you ever imagine that that would be true for you?
当你还在那儿长大，当你一辈子都住在那里，在你搬到蒙大拿之前，你曾想象过会有这么一天吗？
No, no. Growing up there, I never even dreamed in my wildest dreams about moving away from there. I just always thought, I'll just meet someone here, and get married, and live the rest of my life here.
不，不。在那里长大时，我甚至从未做梦想到过要搬离那里。我一直想，我就在那儿遇个人，结婚，在那里过完余生。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
I guess your dream didn't come true. Is that OK with you?
我想你的梦没有实现。这没关系吗？
Oh yeah, yeah. As difficult as it was moving to Bozeman the first few years and all the changes, it really, for all of us, was a good move.
噢，当然，没关系。尽管搬到博兹曼的前几年很困难，经历了所有改变，但这对我们所有人来说，确实是个不错的举动。
Sarah Vowell's move to big-city Bozeman was so successful that she decided to repeat the experience. She move to Portland, population 500,000, Washington DC, population 600,000, San Francisco, population 700,000, and then, finally, Chicago, population 2.8 million.
莎拉·沃威尔搬到大城市博兹曼非常成功，以至于她决定重复这种经历。她搬到了人口50万的波特兰，人口60万的华盛顿特区，人口70万的旧金山，最后是人口280万的芝加哥。
Act Two. How do you keep them going down on the farm? Marry 'em. All across America, people are moving away from small towns and rural areas in steady streams. So if you have stayed in a place where there aren't many people, and the ones that are there you've know since birth, how are you going to find somebody to marry? Well, you might join Singles In Agriculture. They hold get-togethers for singles all over the country. Reporter Liz Weil went with This American Life producer Alix Spiegel to a recent get-together in Galveston, Texas, at the Flagship Hotel on the beach, jutting out onto the water. There were about 250 people from 26 states at meals and meetings, day trips, and dances.
第二幕。怎么让他们留在农场？嫁给他们。在美国各地，人们正源源不断地搬离小镇和农村地区。所以如果你留在一个人口稀少的地方，而且那里的人你从小就认识，你要怎么找到结婚对象呢？好吧，你可能会加入“农业单身族”（SIA）。他们在全国各地为单身人士举行聚会。记者利兹·威尔和《美国生活》制片人阿利克斯·斯皮格尔一起参加了最近在德克萨斯州加尔维斯顿海滩上一家伸进水里的旗舰酒店举办的聚会。有来自26个州的约250人参加了聚会、会议、日游和舞会。
Jim's an extreme case-- smart, charming, 52, looks 40, living on a farm outside Iona, South Dakota, population four. It's 30 miles to the nearest grocery store. The weather is so punishing, cows freeze solid standing up. His dilemma, nobody wants to move to his ranch, and he doesn't want to leave.
吉姆是一个极端的例子——聪明、迷人，52岁，看着像40岁，住在南达科他州爱奥纳外面的农场，人口4人。距离最近的杂货店有30英里远。天气恶劣到牛都会站着冻僵。他的两难境地是，没人愿意搬到他的牧场，而他也不想离开。
This is not bragging on myself or anything, but I have had a girl offer to buy me a farm in another state if I would move and marry her, but I just can't leave it.
这不是吹嘘自己，但曾有女孩提出，如果我肯搬过去并嫁给我，她愿意为我在其他州买个农场，但我就是离不开这里。
Was that a hard choice?
那是很难的选择吗？
Yes, yes it was. I couldn't see why, if I meant that much to her, why she couldn't move there to my place and stuff. And yes, her land had been in her family for a long time, I guess it's--
是，是的。我不明白，如果我对她那么重要，为什么她不能搬到我这里来。而且是的，她的土地在她们家已经传承很久了，我想那是——
This is a typical problem for people in SIA. They're all farmers, all tied to their land, though Jim's situation is particularly harsh. He tells me he realized that a few years ago when the group's director went out to visit him. Even she was stunned by how isolated he was. She said it would take a remarkable woman to move to his ranch.
这是SIA成员的典型问题。他们都是农民，都与土地紧密相连，尽管吉姆的情况特别严峻。他告诉我，几年前当该组织的负责人去探望他时，他才意识到这点。连她都对他竟然如此孤立感到震惊。她说，得是一个非凡的女性才愿意搬到他的牧场。
So do  you, realistically, think that you're going to get married?
那么你现实地认为你会结婚吗？
I would like to. I guess it's always in the back of your mind, you would hope to. But you want an honest answer. I don't think it's going to happen. It's going to take a special girl. You're a city girl, both of you are. I'd ask you, would you be willing to live out, even give the consideration of living out, and trying something like that?
我想的。我想这总是在你的脑后，你会希望如此。但你想要诚实的回答。我不认为会发生。那需要一个特别的女孩。你们是城市女孩，两位都是。我问你们，你们愿意住在那儿，甚至考虑住在那儿，尝试那样的生活吗？
Jim's own mother even admitted that, had she known where she'd been moving, she might not have married his father and moved to the land. It's Thursday night, the first night of the get-together, and we're all at a dance in a Victorian gazebo, with wood floors so old, women have been asked to wear boots, not heels. Everyone's so happy to be here. I have the sense I'm talking to people who don't get to talk to other human beings enough.
吉姆的母亲甚至承认，如果她早知道自己要搬到哪儿，她可能就不会嫁给他父亲并搬到那块土地上。这是周四晚上，聚会的第一个晚上，我们都在一个维多利亚式的凉亭里跳舞，木地板太老了，女士们被要求穿靴子，不能穿高跟鞋。每个人都为能来到这里而感到高兴。我觉得我在和那些没机会与其他人类充分交流的人交谈。
About 10:00, I sit down next to Martha, a twice-widowed woman from Indiana. She's small and nearly 60, wearing a sweatshirt she has decorated with glitter and beads. SIA is the focus of her life.
大约10点，我坐在玛莎旁边，一位来自印第安纳州的两次丧偶女性。她个子娇小，快60岁了，穿着一件用亮片和珠子装饰的运动衫。SIA是她生活的中心。
It gives me something to live for, because I'm very lonely, and I need this to keep me going. Because the first camp-out I went to, I cried when it was time to go home. And they was singing church music, and I couldn't sing, I was crying so hard. And I was giving everybody hugs. I love hugs. Then this one guy just held me, and held me. He said, are you OK? He just held me, and held me till I got calmed down. I said, it just shows how lonely I am, I guess.
它给了我活下去的动力，因为我非常孤独，我需要这个来支持我。因为我参加的第一次露营，回家的时候我哭了。他们唱着教堂的歌，我唱不出来，因为哭得太厉害了。我在给每个人拥抱。我喜欢拥抱。然后一个男人只是抱着我，抱着我。他说，你还好吗？他只是抱着我，一直抱着我，直到我平静下来。我说，我想这正显示了我有多孤独。
Martha tells me that her favorite dance is The Waterfall. How it works is that the women form one line, the men form another, and the two meet in the middle like a zipper, couples dancing up the floor. Martha tells me she likes The Waterfall because you don't need a partner. You just stand in line, and the line moves. You pull a body close, get hugged.
玛莎告诉我，她最喜欢的舞是“瀑布”。它是这样运作的，女士们排成一行，男士们排成另一行，两人像拉链一样在中间汇合，伴侣舞动着穿过舞池。玛莎告诉我她喜欢“瀑布”是因为你不需要固定舞伴。你只需要排队，队伍就会移动。你把一个人拉近，得到一个拥抱。
The next day is Friday. Half the farmers board yellow buses for the NASA Space Center. The other half trek to Houston for a World's Fair-style livestock show. About every 15 minutes, over the course of the day, somebody tries to convince me, no, this group isn't about hooking up, it's about friendship, camaraderie, everyone's one big family. But later in the afternoon, I bump into a group of SIA women who are clearly on the make. One's just bought a t-shirt that reads, cowboy butts drive me nuts.
第二天是周五。一半的农民坐上黄色校车去NASA航天中心。另一半人去休斯顿参加世博会风格的牲畜展。在这一天里，每隔15分钟左右，就会有人试图说服我，不，这个团体不是为了猎艳，是为了友谊、同志情谊，每个人都是一个大家庭。但那天下午晚些时候，我撞见了一群SIA的女性，她们显然是冲着找对象去的。一个刚买了一件T恤，上面写着“牛仔裤里的屁股让我疯狂”。
Maroon shirt ladies, maroon shirt, to the left.
穿栗色衬衫的女士们，栗色衬衫，到左边来。
Oh, when we were eating, oh, jeez did they walk past us.
噢，当我们吃饭的时候，天哪，他们走过我们身边。
No, no, the best one was the guy that was showing the palomino horse. He was good.
不，不，最好的是那个展示帕洛米诺马的家伙。他很不错。
I'm looking at the guy in the black hat right here.
我正盯着这边戴黑帽子的家伙看。
So what do you look for in the jeans, Lee's, Levi's, Wrangler's?
那你喜欢什么样的牛仔裤，Lee牌、Levi's、Wrangler's？
What's in them.
我喜欢穿在里面的那个人。
These  girls are a rowdy, hardcore bunch. They're youngish, around 30, loud, constantly making cracks. Kate, the most vocal of them, is broad and strong, a dairy cow wrangler from Wisconsin. In this crowd, she plays the tomboy. She brags about telling the men she dances with that if someone wants to pick a fight, she'll do the punching. But once alone in her hotel room, her tough girl attitude fades away.
这些女孩是一群吵闹的硬核派。她们正年轻，大约30岁，声音洪亮，不断地开玩笑。凯特，她们中最爱说话的一个，身材魁梧，是来自威斯康星州的奶牛牧人。在这个人群中，她扮演假小子的角色。她吹嘘说她会告诉和她跳舞的男人，如果有人想挑衅，她会挥拳回击。但一旦独自待在酒店房间里，她女汉子的姿态就会消失。
I think of myself as a lady. If you treat me like a lady, I mean, I treat them well. I guess, I'm more traditional, older-fashioned, I guess they call it.
我觉得自己是个淑女。如果你把我当淑女对待，我就也会对他好。我想，我更传统，更老派，我想他们是这么称呼的。
She goes on to tell me about a friend of hers, a woman who prayed every night to meet somebody and eventually did.
她接着告诉我关于她一个朋友的事，一个每晚祈祷能遇到某人并最终如愿以偿的女性。
So do you do that? Do you pray about what the kind of person--?
那你也那样做吗？你会为你要遇到什么样的人祈祷吗——？
What? Well, yeah. I mean, you pray that God leads you or guides you to, or guides him and you to meet sometime, and what kind of guy you would like. And she told me, be specific. You can't just say a guy that's got two legs, a hat, and whatever, a belt buckle.
什么？嗯，是的。我是说，你会祈祷上帝引领或指导你，或者指导他和你会面，以及你想要什么样的男人。她告诉我，要具体。你不能只说一个有两条腿、一顶帽子、腰带扣的男人。
So are you following her directions? Are you being specific?
那你遵循她的指示了吗？你有具体化吗？
No, I mean, I do this, like, every night.
没有，我是说，我每天晚上都这样做。
This going to smell terrible.
这闻起来太糟糕了。
Oh, it does.
噢，确实。
Down the hall from Kate are Ernie and Sally, a couple who met through SIA. He's 50ish, from Oklahoma, grows sesame and delivers mail. She's a school teacher from Kansas, incredibly hot, in a short, tight dress and baby-doll tee. At this point in their relationship, they only book one hotel room. And right now, Ernie is in there fixing Sally's boot. The smell of epoxy is mind-numbing. They detail their first date.
在凯特的走廊对面是厄尼和萨莉，一对通过SIA认识的夫妇。他50出头，来自俄克拉荷马州，种植芝麻并担任邮递员。她是一名来自堪萨斯的学校老师，非常火辣，穿着短而紧的连衣裙和娃娃衫。此时他们的关系中，他们只订了一个酒店房间。现在，厄尼正在里面修理萨莉的靴子。环氧树脂的味道令人麻木。他们详细描述了他们的第一次约会。
We were going to a dance, Halloween dance, and I got to her house.
我们当时要去跳舞，万圣节舞会，我到了她家。
Driving six hours to get there.
开车六个小时才到那儿。
Drove six hours to get there, and in less then 15 minutes, she was begging me to take her dress off.
开了六小时车，不到15分钟，她就在求我脱掉她的裙子了。
OK, let me explain. Ernie had brought over a blue flapper dress. His former wife had made it. Sally wanted to look at it, maybe wear it as a costume.
好啦，让我解释一下。厄尼带来了一件蓝色拍拍舞裙。他前妻做的。萨莉想看看，也许可以当作戏服穿。
I get there, and she's, oh, I got to try that dress on. She looked at it. She ran in the bathroom and put this dress on. And I waited, and I waited, and pretty soon I heard this, Ernie.
我到了那儿，她说，哦，我得试试那条裙子。她看了看。她跑进浴室把裙子穿上了。我等啊等，很快我听到这个，厄尼。
Well, I put the dress on.
好吧，我穿上那件裙子了。
Help me.
帮帮我。
And it was tight. It was really tight. So we kind of stand there and talk awhile, and I'm just thinking--
而且它很紧。真的很紧。所以我们就在那儿站着聊了一会儿，我只是在想——
And I said, well, what do I do? And I was, where do you grab?
然后我说，好吧，我该怎么做？我就问，你往哪抓？
He goes, where do you want me to get a hold of you?
他回答说，你想让我往哪儿抓？
Both Ernie and Sally lost their spouses. They both felt sparks five or six months ago when they first met. They live a reasonable distance apart by SIA standards, but, and this is the problem with a national organization of rural singles, the logistics make it nearly impossible to date.
厄尼和萨莉都失去了配偶。五六个月前他们第一次见面时都感到火花四溅。按照SIA的标准，他们住得距离适中，但——这是全国农村单身组织的问题——后勤使得约会几乎不可能。
404 miles from my door to his door.
从我家门口到他家门口有404英里。
And how often do you get a chance to see each other?
你们多久有机会见一次面？
About every two weeks we get together, every couple weeks. It's a good six-hour drive. I don't care how you go. Phone bills are pretty high, too. Be a lot cheaper if you married me, wouldn't it? He says I push him a little bit. Can you believe that?
大约每两周聚一次。开车至少要六个小时，无论你怎么走。电话费也很高。嫁给我会便宜得多，不是吗？他说我有点逼他。你能相信吗？
I can't believe that. Do you feel like she pushes you a little bit?
我不敢相信。你觉得她逼你了吗？
No, not a little bit, a whole lot.
不，不是一点点，是逼得很紧。
Sally and Ernie have this little routine. Like most set pieces couples have, it's only half in jest. She ribs him constantly about getting married, he hedges. They love each other, but they're at different points in their lives.
萨莉和厄尼有这个小套路。像大多数固定伴侣那样，这只是一半开玩笑。她不断地拿结婚的事取笑他，他则回避。他们爱着对方，但他们处于生命中不同的阶段。
How long you been single?
你单身多久了？
11 years. Husband died, had a heart attack.
11年了。丈夫去世了，心脏病发作。
And I've been a year and eight months. So I've got about a year before I might decide whether I'm going to do anything and who with.
我单身了一年八个月。所以我还有大约一年时间来决定我是否要做什么，以及和谁一起。
Ernie didn't expect to meet somebody so quickly. In fact, he wasn't sure he'd meet somebody at all. He married young, didn't have many girlfriends before that. Right now, this is his first round of dating. It's a heady experience, and one he's not ready to give up yet.
厄尼没想到会这么快遇到某人。事实上，他不确定自己是否会遇到任何人。他结婚很早，之前没交过几个女朋友。现在，这是他的第一轮约会。这是一种令人兴奋的经历，他还没准备好放弃。
Women knew, if you're widowed, they're interested. It's definitely a plus over someone that's divorced.
女人们知道，如果你是鳏夫，她们很感兴趣。这绝对比离婚的要有优势。
Friday night is the second dance. And when I bump into Ernie, he's passing out these business cards. They have rainbows on them, and they read, Ernest Ernie W. Schmidt, married 32 years, widowed, I'm attracted to you, let's be good friends. Sally, as you might imagine, is not so thrilled about this. She has enough good friends, at least for the time being. While Ernie mingles, we talk to her in the back room.
周五晚上是第二次舞会。当我撞见厄尼时，他正在分发这些名片。上面有彩虹，写着：“欧内斯特·厄尼·W·施密特，已婚32年，丧偶，我被你吸引了，让我们做个好朋友吧”。萨莉，你可以想象，对此并不怎么兴奋。至少暂时来说，她有足够的好朋友了。当厄尼去社交时，我们在后台房间和她谈话。
Oh, I would marry him. I mean, if we break up, I'm going to just be heartbroken. It's going to be really bad, because my husband's been gone for 11 years, and I haven't met anybody that I would marry but Ernie.
噢，我会嫁给他。我是说，如果我们分手了，我会心碎的。那会很糟糕，因为我丈夫已经离开11年了，除了厄尼，我还没见过任何我想嫁的人。
Sally stops her interview, saying she better get back to Ernie. She's worried that he'll miss her. A moment later, we head out from the back room. I see Ernie with a blond woman, two-stepping on the dance floor. Half an hour later, we run into Ernie and Sally kissing on the veranda. Sometime after this, Sally sends me a note. On the envelope she writes, in all capitals, I WILL MARRY ERNIE SOMEDAY.
萨莉停止了采访，说她最好回到厄尼身边。她担心他会想念她。片刻之后，我们从后台走出。我看到厄尼和一个金发女人在舞池里跳舞。半小时后，我们在阳台上碰见厄尼和萨莉在亲吻。在那之后不久，萨莉寄给我一张便条。在信封上，她用全大写字母写道：我总有一天会嫁给厄尼。
The night starts winding down, at least I think it starts winding down until I realize something, nobody's planning on going to sleep. The people who come to SIA spend a lot of time alone. They crave company, affection, basic human contact. It's past midnight when the farmers leave the gazebo and return to the Flagship Hotel. Everybody's tired, but they don't go to bed. The hit the beach.
夜晚开始结束，至少我觉得它开始结束了，直到我意识到一件事：没人打算睡觉。来到SIA的人独自度过了很多时间。他们渴望陪伴、关怀和基本的人类接触。午夜已过，农民们离开凉亭回到旗舰酒店。每个人都很累，但他们没有去睡觉。他们去了海滩。
Come on, I got to show you something out there.
来吧，我得给你看点东西。
Just remember, I'm a very strong girl.
记住，我是个非常强壮的女孩。
Jim, the first guy I talked to back at the first dance, drags a fully clothed women into the water.
吉姆，那个我在第一次舞会谈到的第一个家伙，把一个穿着全套衣服的女人拖进了水里。
Ah, you're crazy. Is it cold?
啊，你疯了。冷吗？
[SQUEALING AND PLAY  SOUNDS FROM THE  SURF]
[海浪声中的尖叫和玩耍声]
There's something really high school-esque about the whole SIA experience. Like right now, the moon is out, the air is salty, and we're in this huge awkward group. And what do people do to cash in on the moment? Pair off? Nope.
整个SIA的经历有一种非常高中时代的感觉。就像现在，月亮出来了，空气里咸咸的，我们处于这群尴尬的人群中。人们会做什么来利用那一刻？结对？不。
[SINGING] Germs, germs, go away--
[歌唱] 病菌，病菌，走开——
They sing.
他们唱歌。
--never, never come to play. I call you ick, you make me sick.
——永远，永远别来找我玩。我叫你讨厌，你让我生病。
Note, none of them has had a drop to drink.
注，他们中没人喝过一滴酒。
[GENERAL APPLAUSE, HOOTING]
[热烈掌声、欢呼声]
Evening winds down, and the couples at SIA head toward the climactic night of their weekend, in a minute, when our program continues.
夜晚接近尾声，SIA的伴侣们正走向他们周末的高潮之夜，稍后，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week we choose a theme, of course, and invite a variety of writers, and reporters, and documentary producers to take a whack at that theme. Today's theme, Small Towns. Liz Weil's story continues about a four-day get together of SIA, Singles In Agriculture.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并邀请各种作家、记者和纪录片制作人来探讨该主题。今天的主题，“小镇”。利兹·威尔关于SIA——“农业单身族”四天聚会的故事继续。
Saturday, we wake up to some incredibly tedious meetings, which, by some heroic faith, people manage to love. It completely undermines all critical standards of what's compelling, what's fun.
周六，我们醒来参加一些极其枯燥的会议，凭着某种英雄般的信念，人们竟然乐在其中。这彻底颠覆了关于什么是吸引人、什么是乐趣的所有批判标准。
Event financial record be forwarded to the national office within 90 days of the last day of the activity.
活动财务记录应在活动结束后的90天内转发给国家办公室。
Later Saturday afternoon, I catch up with Martha, the woman who told me that SIA gives her reason to live. She's in her room, sewing the final beads on a sweater she's making for tonight's banquet and flag ceremony. The handiwork seems to relax her. She's got this other sweatshirt, her hug sweatshirt, that she wears at the end of every SIA retreat.
周六下午晚些时候，我追上了玛莎，那个告诉我SIA给了她活下去理由的女人。她在房间里，为今晚的宴会和旗帜仪式缝制一件毛衣上的最后一颗珠子。这手工活似乎让她放松了下来。她还有另一件运动衫，她的“拥抱运动衫”，每次SIA撤退时她都会穿。
I met this friend, and she sent me this bookmark about why God made hugs. And I don't remember it, but I had my daughter enlarge it on the computer and put it on a scroll. And I put it on the sweatshirt. And I tell people that I didn't invent the hugs, God did, because he gives a reason in this poem why. And you've seen pictures of how much he loves us, and stretches out his arms. And I like hugs.
我遇到了这位朋友，她寄给我这个关于上帝为什么创造拥抱的书签。我不记得具体内容，但我让女儿在电脑上把它放大并放在卷轴上。我把它缝在运动衫上。我告诉人们我没发明拥抱，是上帝发明的，因为他在诗里给出了理由。你们看过上帝有多爱我们、伸出双臂的图片。而我喜欢拥抱。
Martha tells me she's a recovering alcoholic. She tells me that one of her children, her daughter, died in 1981. She works evenings at Kmart, because she can't stand to spend her nights alone.
玛莎告诉我她是康复中的酒鬼。她告诉我，她的一个孩子，她女儿，在1981年去世了。她在Kmart上夜班，因为她无法忍受独自度过夜晚。
It seems like I've had so many bad things happen in my life that now something good is happening, meeting these people. My friend in Florida thinks I ought to go to AA and tell my story, Because she said, Martha, you've been through wars.
似乎我生活中发生过太多糟糕的事，现在终于有些好事发生了，遇到了这些人。我在佛罗里达的朋友觉得我应该去参加AA并讲述我的故事，因为她说，玛莎，你经历过战争。
Martha goes on to tell me that before SIA events, she gets so excited that she worries that she'll have a heart attack or a stroke. People spend a lot of time getting ready for Saturday night's banquet. Women wear dresses with slits and sequins. Men wear jackets, bolo ties. This is the big event, the final showdown. The evening starts with a prayer.
玛莎接着告诉我，在SIA活动之前，她太兴奋了，以至于她担心自己会心脏病发作或中风。人们花费大量时间准备周六晚上的宴会。女士们穿着有开叉和亮片的裙子。男士们穿着夹克、波洛领带。这是重头戏，最后的摊牌。晚上以祈祷开始。
We take pause before you God, acknowledging we can rest quietly in your arms, with confidence and assurance of your love, grace, and mercy, as we walk through this season called singledness, as we ask, hope, and believe all things in the name of Jesus Christ, Amen. OK, flag bearers, here we go.
我们在上帝面前停顿，承认我们可以安静地在你的怀里休息，对你的爱、恩典和怜悯充满信心和保证，当我们走过这个被称为单身的季节时，正如我们以耶稣基督的名祈祷、希望和相信一切一样，阿门。好了，旗手们，我们走吧。
What's going on here is really rather incredible. There are 50 men and women lined up in long aisles by twos. Each person is bearing a flimsy, nylon handkerchief-sized flag on a long, thin pole. It would be campy if people's eyes weren't so reverent, so serious. They march towards the front of the room. After dinner, a man gives a very boring talk on Russian agriculture. Plaques are awarded to old board members. Election results are announced for the new. At the end of the banquet, Eldon, the outgoing president, gets up to make a speech. He's good-looking, jovial, in his 40s. He beats the podium nervously with his hand. A smile creeps across his face.
这里发生的事真是太不可思议了。有50名男士和女士在长长的过道里排成两行。每个人都拿着一面廉价的、尼龙手帕大小的旗子，杆子又长又细。如果不是人们的眼神那么虔诚、那么严肃，这会很俗气。他们向房间前方前进。晚饭后，一名男子对俄罗斯农业发表了一场非常无聊的演讲。奖章颁发给了旧董事会成员。宣布了新任人员的选举结果。宴会结束时，即将卸任的主席埃尔登站起来发表讲话。他长相英俊，快活，40多岁。他紧张地用手敲打着讲台。一丝微笑浮现在他的脸上。
So I guess I got one more thing I got to say, or I'm going to be a dead duck before this night is over. A year ago, I could not find hired help to go on harvest. I was ticked off, I don't mind telling you. My income was just plummeting like a rock. Well, I got to go to Indiana. We got a board meeting. And I'm not harvesting, so I don't have an excuse. I met somebody there that, she probably won't like this, but at the time, didn't really help my mood that much. Fortunately, she didn't give up, and she stayed in contact with me. So you people, you got to remember, I've been in this thing a long time. And I guess I wouldn't say that I had given up, but I really wasn't searching that hard. And I found somebody, and it's going to result in a wedding dance April the 5, and anybody--
所以我猜我还有一件事要说，否则今晚结束前我就得死掉了。一年前，我找不到帮手去收割。我气坏了，不瞒你们说。我的收入像石头一样直线下滑。好吧，我去印第安纳州参加董事会会议。我没在收割，所以我没借口。我在那儿遇到了一个人，她可能不喜欢这样，但当时，并没有真正改善我的心情。幸运的是，她没有放弃，她和我保持联系。所以各位，你们得记住，我参加这活动很久了。我猜我不能说我已经放弃了，但我确实没那么努力地在寻找。但我找到了某人，这将在4月5日举行婚礼舞会，任何人——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Everybody stands up and claps and hollers for what seems like a good 10 minutes. People are so exquisitely happy, wistful, jealous, and proud. The scene feels oddly like the end of a Miss America Pageant. Women cry and clasp hands over their mouths. When the ovation fades, they gather around the bride-to-be.
每个人都站起来拍手、欢呼，持续了大概足足10分钟。人们是那么精致地快乐、渴望、嫉妒和自豪。这一幕感觉莫名其妙地像“美国小姐”选美大赛的结局。女人们哭泣着，双手合十放在嘴边。当欢呼声减弱时，她们围拢在新娘周围。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] I'm so proud. I'm so glad.
[难以辨认] 我太骄傲了。我太高兴了。
So am I. I'm so happy.
我也是。我太幸福了。
I bet you are.
我敢说你是。
I'll bet you are. Whoo hoo.
我敢说你是。呜呼。
In the crowd, I see Martha looking overwhelmed. She embraces Eldon's fiancee.
在人群中，我看到玛莎显得不知所措。她拥抱了埃尔登的未婚妻。
Oh, quite a shock. Oh, but you're so lucky.
噢，真是个惊喜。噢，但你太幸运了。
I think I'm lucky, too. No, I'm not lucky, I'm blessed.
我觉得我也很幸运。不，我不幸运，我是蒙福的。
I know I'm not supposed to envy people, but I do.
我知道我不应该嫉妒别人，但我嫉妒。
I'm blessed. Keep looking, Martha.
我是蒙福的。继续寻找，玛莎。
I want love so bad.
我太想要爱了。
By tonight at the dance, any reserve the farmer's had has pretty much faded away. There's more winking, more flirting, more moving of hips, less chat about seed corn around the edges of the room. When the "Macarena" cues up, Jim shakes his South Dakota booty with heartbreaking deliberateness and intent. Meanwhile, Kate, the tomboy with the eye for cowboy butts, remains in the back of the room. She spent most of her evening tangling with Rod, a tall, crazy-haired rancher who apparently does not like to dance. From 10:00 to 11:00, they pull and punch each other, get to know one another's bodies by yanking skirts and stealing hats. It's classic mating, junior high style. When they head out on the veranda, my producer and I follow.
到今晚舞会时，农民们的所有矜持几乎都已经消散了。房间边缘少了一些关于种子玉米的聊天，多了更多的眨眼、调情、臀部摆动。当“玛卡莱娜”响起时，吉姆带着令人心碎的深思熟虑和意图摆动着他的南达科他屁股。与此同时，那个喜欢牛仔屁股的假小子凯特依然待在房间后面。她今晚大部分时间都在和罗德纠缠，罗德是一个高个子、头发乱糟糟的牧场主，显然不喜欢跳舞。从10点到11点，他们互相拉扯挥拳，通过拽裙子和抢帽子来熟悉彼此的身体。这是经典的求偶，初中风格。当他们走向阳台时，我的制作人和我跟了过去。
So how is your night going?
那么你的夜晚过得怎么样？
How's my night going? It's all right.
我的夜晚过得怎么样？还行。
Any excitement?
有什么兴奋的事吗？
[LAUGHTER] Any excitement, depends whose excitement we're talking about.
[笑声] 有什么兴奋的事吗，取决于我们在说谁的兴奋。
Yours.
你的。
Well, it's different.
嗯，这不一样。
Kate's been working on Rod since early this morning. They have similar ages, energy levels, goofy karmas. While Kate's been talking to us, Rod's been leaning on the railing, a couple of yards away. Just now, though, a tall brunette walks over and starts chatting him up. Kate doesn't move. She just gets quiet, and loses interest in our interview entirely.
凯特从今天一大早就在纠缠罗德。他们年龄相仿，活力相当，有那种古怪的业力。当凯特和我们说话时，罗德正斜靠在几码外的栏杆上。然而，就在这时，一个高个子的黑发女人走过去开始和他搭讪。凯特没动。她只是安静下来，完全对我们的采访失去了兴趣。
Listen, I can't [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. I got to listen to this girl talk over here, because she's like, she's saying, you're the most handsome guy here. That's what she's telling him. I can sure see that. I mean, I don't have to look at people, but I can hear what the hell they're talking about. And when I hear my name mentioned, I perked up a little bit.
听着，我不能[无法辨认的短语]。我得听那个女孩在说什么，因为她像是，她说，你是这里最英俊的男人。她就是那么告诉他的。我肯定能看出来。我是说，我不必盯着人看，但我能听到他们在谈论什么鬼东西。当我听到我的名字被提到时，我振作了一点。
She's talking about you over there?
她在说你吗？
No, she's not talking. She's after that guy. I mean, I knew that. She was with us today.
不，她没在说。她在追那个家伙。我是说，我知道。她今天和我们在一起。
She's after Rod? That guy? She's after that guy?
她在追罗德？那个家伙？她在追那个家伙？
Shh. See, I can just stand over here and make like I'm talking to you guys, and I can hear everything.
嘘。看，我可以就站在一边装作在和你们说话，我什么都能听到。
Tell us what she's saying.
告诉我们她在说什么。
She says-- she said something about play into this. Listen. Oh, she's going back. She ain't going to talk to him anymore. I'm going to see-- Oh, he's not going back.
她说——她说了些关于参与其中的话。听。噢，她回去了。她不再和他说话了。我要看看——噢，他没回去。
Kate snags Rod, and the two of them walk back into the gazebo. It's clear that this is only a minor glitch. The dance ends at midnight. Kate and Rod hop in a cab and head downtown. We make for the hotel. Jim offers us a ride in his van, which he bought especially for SIA events, and which feels like a huge babe trap. The van is dark red and finely upholstered. Riding shotgun is Marie.
凯特抓住了罗德，两人走回凉亭。很明显这只是个小插曲。舞会在午夜结束。凯特和罗德跳上一辆出租车往市中心去了。我们往酒店走。吉姆主动提出开他的面包车送我们，那是他特意为SIA活动买的，感觉就像是个巨大的诱饵。面包车是深红色的，内饰精美。坐在副驾驶的是玛丽。
We're going to the hospitality room.
我们要去招待室。
Where you going?
你们去哪儿？
We're living it up. Where are you going?
我们要去玩个痛快。你们去哪儿？
Don't know yet.
还不知道。
Don't know yet?
还不知道？
We'll find something.
我们会找到些什么的。
We'll go back to Marie's room and party, huh?
我们要回玛丽的房间聚会，嗯？
Yeah, let's go to my room and party.
是啊，我们去我房间聚会吧。
Major plans decided, the moment gets more personal. This is the time for putting on moves, to make something happen tonight.
重大计划确定后，那一刻变得更加私密。这是施展招数的时候，为了今晚能发生点什么。
This is my kind of music. What kind of music do you girls like?
这是我喜欢的音乐。你们女孩喜欢什么音乐？
Well, this is OK, but I--
嗯，这还行，但我——
It's just OK, huh? Cat got your tongue?
只是还行，嗯？被猫咬了舌头？
Later people, mostly men, sit around the hospitality suite. Jim pokes his head in. He grins and tells us that he's going upstairs with Marie. At 5:00 in the morning, Rod and Kate sheepishly come back from downtown. In the morning, the weekend ends with an egg and sausage breakfast, "Amazing Grace," and the SIA tradition of everybody hugging everybody else in the room.
后来，人们，主要是男人，坐在招待套房里。吉姆探出头来。他笑着告诉我们他要和玛丽上楼。凌晨5点，罗德和凯特羞答答地从市中心回来。早上，周末在鸡蛋香肠早餐、“奇异恩典”和SIA拥抱房间里每个人的传统中结束。
Everybody looks exhausted, like students after exams. Martha spends a long time crying at the window, watching the cars pull out, talking about how she already misses the hugs. She's wearing her special hugs sweatshirt, the one with the poem sewn on the front. The loop appears to be starting over. Martha's returning to her empty trailer in Indiana, where she'll be lonely, and work evenings at Kmart, and save up her money for the next SIA event. But then something happens. A man pulls a game store coin out of his pocket. He gives it to her. She reads aloud.
每个人看起来都筋疲力尽，就像考完试的学生。玛莎在窗前哭了很久，看着汽车驶离，说着她已经开始想念拥抱了。她穿着那件特别的拥抱运动衫，前面缝着那首诗。循环似乎要重新开始了。玛莎回到她印第安纳州空荡荡的拖车里，她会在那里感到孤独，在Kmart上夜班，并为下一次SIA活动存钱。但后来发生了一件事。一个男人从口袋里掏出一枚游戏店硬币。他给了她。她大声读出来。
Good for a hug and a kiss anytime, anywhere. It doesn't say, any place. Can I have it?
随时随地，可以兑换一个拥抱和一个吻。它没说，“任何地方”。我可以拥有它吗？
No, it's the only one I got.
不，这是我唯一的。
Will you make a copy?
你能复印一份吗？
OK.
好吧。
Well, give me my kiss.
好吧，给我我的吻。
Here, in front of everybody?
在这里，在所有人面前？
Yeah, God too. God's watching.
是啊，上帝也在。上帝在看着。
Oh, my gosh.
噢，天哪。
When the two come out of the kiss, they both seem surprised. At the outset, they both expected a peck. But in the middle, something else kicked in. Something so basic, that when it hits you, you don't ask why.
当两人吻完分开时，他们似乎都很惊讶。起初，他们都以为只是轻吻一下。但在中间，某种别的东西起作用了。某种如此基础的东西，当它袭来时，你不会问为什么。
Hey, it's been a long time since I had  a kiss.
嘿，我已经很久没接过吻了。
Act Three, Small town in the big city. The fact is a small town can be anywhere, even in the heart of what many people see as one of the harshest urban environments in the country. Paul Johnson, Carlos Appleby, and Sanantonio Brooks are teenagers living in public housing on Chicago's South Side at 4120 South Prairie. People who live there just call the building, 4120. It's a highrise building, 16 stories tall, 10 apartments on each floor, with an open air hallway on each floor that people who live there just call a porch. We sent them out with a tape recorder to their building to record what happens there, and then talked to them in our studios about how their building is like a small town.
第三幕，大城市里的小镇。事实是，小镇可以在任何地方，甚至在许多人视为该国最严酷的城市环境之一的中心。保罗·约翰逊、卡洛斯·阿普尔比和萨南托尼奥·布鲁克斯是住在芝加哥南区普雷里南街4120号公共住房里的青少年。住在那里的人管这栋楼叫4120。这是一栋高层建筑，16层高，每层10间公寓，每层都有一个露天走廊，住在那里的人管它叫“门廊”。我们给他们一台录音机，让他们回到楼里记录那里发生的事情，然后在我们的工作室里和他们谈论他们的楼怎么像个小镇。
You can get haircuts there. Girls can get their hair done, their nails done in there.
你在那儿可以理发。女孩们可以在里面做头发，做指甲。
Clothes, somebody that make clothes in the building.
衣服，有人在楼里做衣服。
There's a candy store on five.
5楼有个糖果店。
Yeah, there's a candy store on five.
是的，5楼有个糖果店。
A real candy store?
真的糖果店吗？
Yeah, a candy store.
是的，糖果店。
A real candy store. There's a real candy store.
真的糖果店。有个真的糖果店。
There's a couple of candy stores in the building.
楼里有好几个糖果店。
And is it like a real candy store? It's like somebody's apartment, they have a little fix-it-up?
那它是像真正的糖果店吗？是像某人的公寓，他们搞了点修理？
Right, they sell food too. It's like our own community inside the building.
对，他们也卖吃的。这就像是我们楼里自己的社区。
Now that we are on the 12th floor at the candy store. They have, like, six different varieties of potato chips, all for $0.25 each. They have penny candy, meaning white candy, Laffy Taffys, and chews and things of that sort. They sell food too. They got Italian [? beefs ?], pizza puffs. The people on the 12th floor, they don't want to do our interview, because they refused. Because they ain't licensed. They didn't have, so we're going down to the fifth floor right now.
现在我们在12楼的糖果店。他们有，像是，六种不同种类的薯片，都只要25美分。他们有小糖果，意思是白色糖果、拉菲太妃糖和嚼劲之类。他们也卖吃的。他们有意大利牛肉，披萨饼。12楼的人，他们不想做我们的采访，因为他们拒绝了。因为他们没营业执照。他们没有，所以我们现在下到5楼去。
Compare the two candy stores, 5th and the 12th, which is the better one?
比较一下两家糖果店，5楼和12楼，哪家更好？
The 12th.
12楼。
Why?
为什么？
The food.
吃的。
They sell food. They sell, like, everything in a real grocery store.
他们卖吃的。他们卖，像，真正的杂货店里的一切。
Everything.
一切。
Every type of game.
每种游戏。
Almost everything you need, pencil, paper, cards. That's really the grocery store of the building.
几乎你需要的一切，铅笔、纸、卡片。那才是楼里的杂货店。
So what happens on the other floors? Tell me about what happens on six. What's it like?
那其他楼层发生什么事？告诉我6楼发生什么。那是什么样？
Six, it just--
6楼，它只是——
That's the place for them little kids. That's where the little kids meet.
那是小孩子待的地方。那是小孩子见面玩耍的地方。
That's where all the little kids be at.
那是所有小孩子待的地方。
That's where all the crumb-snatchers run and play.
那是所有“小屁孩”跑来跑去玩耍的地方。
[YELLS]
[尖叫]
[SQUEALING KIDS]
[小孩尖叫声]
What games do you all play? You all play, it?
你们都玩什么游戏？你们玩抓人游戏吗？
It, yeah, It. Ghosts. We play hopscotch. We play Bingo. Bingo. Bingo was his name oh. And And we play the Mario game.
抓人，是的，抓人。鬼魂。我们玩跳房子。我们玩宾果。宾果，宾果是他的名字噢。而且我们玩马里奥游戏。
You all don't hang with no boys?
你们都不跟男孩子一起玩？
No! No!
不！不！
What, boys yucky?
怎么，男孩子很讨厌？
Yeah!
是的！
They nasty?
他们很恶心？
Yeah!
是的！
That's why you all don't like boys?
这就是为什么你们不喜欢男孩子？
Yeah! No!
是的！不！
12th floor--
12楼——
13 might as well be the Twilight Zone, don't nobody live up there.
13楼简直就是“阴阳魔界”，根本没人住在上面。
Right, no, nobody ever.
对，没人，从来没人。
And it's always dark.
而且它总是黑的。
Nobody's living in any of those apartments?
那些公寓里没人住吗？
Yeah, they live there, but it seem like they don't.
是的，他们住在那里，但看起来好像没住。
It's just dark.
它只是黑的。
And on nine and eight, that's where, eight and seven, that's where all the fights at. You want to see a fight, for sure, there's going to be a fight on one of those floors.
在9楼和8楼，那是，8楼和7楼，那是所有打架发生的地方。如果你想看打架，肯定，在这些楼层之一会有架打。
And why those floors?
为什么是那些楼层？
Because that's where most people hang out, on the nine, eight, and seven.
因为那是大多数人闲逛的地方，在9楼、8楼和7楼。
Right, there's a fight, or you can play games or whatever you want to do.
对，有打架，或者你可以玩游戏或做任何你想做的事。
So what we want to do, play cards while you all get tea? [SINGING] In love with Mary Jane.
那我们想做什么，你们喝茶的时候我们玩牌？[唱歌] 爱上玛丽·珍。
OK, now you guys should explain where we are.
好了，现在你们得解释我们在哪儿。
Right now, we're on the eighth floor, in apartment 801.
现在，我们在8楼，801室。
And is this a card game that happens all the time?
这是经常发生的打牌游戏吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Now, are these guys your age or are they older?
这些人是你们这么大还是年龄大点的？
Older.
大的。
Yeah, 21, 22, and up.
是的，21岁、22岁以上。
What card game are they playing?
他们在玩什么牌游戏？
Spades.
黑桃。
Of the three of you, who's the best card player?
你们三个人里，谁是最好的牌手？
Me.
我。
OK, let's play a little more of the tape.
好吧，让我们听听录音带的更多内容。
You ain't got no [BLEEP] job. How the [BLEEP] can you get fired on your day off? Man! What you got to be? You got to be a stupid [BLEEP] to get fired on your day off.
你没有[哔]工作。你他妈怎么能在休息日被解雇？伙计！你得是什么人？你得是个愚蠢的[哔]才能在休息日被解雇。
Now, I've got to say, now when you first played this tape, when you first gave this tape to producer Nancy Updike and I, we heard this and we thought, yeah, how do you lose your job on your day off? Like, what is this with these guys? But in fact, there is something else going on here, isn't there?
现在，我得说，当你第一次播放这段录音，当你第一次把这段录音给制作人南希·厄普代克和我时，我们听到这个，我们心想，是的，你怎么会在休息日丢了工作？像是，这些家伙是怎么回事？但实际上，这里还有其他事情在发生，不是吗？
Yeah, they was acting out the movie, Friday . That was like one of the scenes in the movie. So they was like, re-acting it.
是的，他们在表演电影《星期五》。那是电影里的场景之一。所以他们像是，在重演它。
Let's hear that scene.
让我们听听那个场景。
You ain't got no job? How the hell you going to get fired on your day off? God damn. You got to be a stupid [BLEEP] to get fired on your day off.
你没有工作？你他妈怎么能在休息日被解雇？该死。你得是个愚蠢的[哔]才能在休息日被解雇。
You guys all act out scenes from movies a lot while you're playing cards?
你们在打牌的时候经常会表演电影场景吗？
Yeah, everybody acting silly, cracking a jokes. That's when you play your best game, when you are relaxed.
是的，每个人都演得傻乎乎的，开玩笑。那是你发挥最好的时候，当你放松的时候。
Now, you actually tried to interview these guys while you sat there playing cards. And you tried for, like, an hour.
现在，你们确实试图在打牌时采访这些家伙。你们尝试了，大约一个小时。
Well, we kept asking them questions over and over, but they pretty much tried to tell nothing, because they thought we was trying to help the law out or something.
嗯，我们一直在问他们问题，反反复复，但他们基本上什么都不想说，因为他们以为我们在试着帮法律或什么。
Yeah, they thought we was with the police.
是的，他们以为我们是警察。
Trying to get indictments out on them, so they ain't want to say nothing.
想搞到对他们的起诉书，所以他们什么都不想说。
How long you been living in this building?
你在这栋楼住多久了？
Like, 10 years.
像是，10年。
10 years?
10年？
Do you consider this building a small town?
你认为这栋楼是个小镇吗？
Yeah, that kid's a [BLEEP] news. Is you a news reporter for real, man?
是的，那个小孩是[哔]新闻。你真的是新闻记者吗，伙计？
Working for the white man.
为白人干活。
I'm just trying to get this story.
我只是想搞到这个故事。
What the [BLEEP] is this?
这[哔]是什么？
I think we better go get the radio and play a song. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] that white man's world.
我想我们最好去把收音机打开放首歌。[无法辨认]那个白人的世界。
So you all calling me white just because I'm asking --
所以你们就因为我问问题就叫我白人——
No sir.
不，先生。
We not, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
我们不是，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。
You think in some ways it is like a small town?
你们认为在某些方面它像个小镇吗？
To me, it is.
对我来说，是。
It is like a small town, because a small town, it's like everybody is family. And a lot of people, like Sanantonio, he got a lot of family in that building.
它像个小镇，因为小镇，像是每个人都是家人。而且很多人，像萨南托尼奥，他在那栋楼里有很多家人。
I believe, we got the most family in there.
我相信，我们在那儿有最多的家人。
Like on every floor, you'll find somebody in his family.
像是每一层，你都会在他家发现某人。
Right, I got the most family. I think I got the most.
对，我有最多的家人。我想我有最多的。
All right, run it down. Let me hear. Who and who floor, give it to me from top to bottom.
好吧，理一理。让我听听。谁在谁那层，从上到下给我说。
The 16th, let me see, I don't really got nobody on the 16th or the 15th. 14, I think I got a cousin. A cousin that's down on 12. 11, I got a grandma that's on 11. The 10th, I got an auntie that's down on the 10th. Well, I stay on the eighth, auntie on the sixth. I stay on the fifth. And my other grandmother stay on the third.
16楼，让我看，16楼和15楼我真的没人。14楼，我想我有一个表亲。有个表亲在12楼。11楼，我有个祖母在11楼。10楼，我有个姨妈在10楼。嗯，我待在8楼，姨妈在6楼。我待在5楼。而且我的另一个祖母待在3楼。
And just let me be sure. When you stay on the fifth, who  are you staying with?
让我确认一下。当你待在5楼时，你是和谁待在一起？
My mother.
我妈。
And  on the eighth?
那8楼呢？
My grandmother.
我祖母。
And you interviewed your grandmother, right?
而且你采访了你的祖母，对吧？
I interviewed my other grandmother. I stay with the one on eighth. But I interviewed the one on the third.
我采访了我的另一个祖母。我和8楼那个住在一起。但我采访了3楼的那个。
And she grew up in a small town,  right?
而且她在小镇长大的，对吧？
Yes, in Mississippi.
是的，在密西西比州。
Do you get homesick to go back down to the South?
你会因为想回南方而思乡吗？
No, you get homesick, I'd go down and visit my mom. But I don't get homesick near as bad anymore. I grew up in the South. I had a rough time in the South. I picked cotton, chopped cotton, picked for a little amount of money. And I chopped cotton from sun-up to sundown and didn't really make very much money. And we didn't have very much down there.
不，你会想家的话，我会下去看看我妈。但我不再那么思乡了。我在南方长大。我在南方过得很苦。我摘棉花、砍棉花，为一点点钱。我从日出砍到日落，真的没赚到多少钱。而且我们在那儿没什么。
If you had a choice, which would you think would be better to raise your children in, this building or back in the South?
如果给你选择，你觉得在哪儿养孩子更好，这栋楼还是南方？
Well, like I said, basically it's the same now, because down South, there's about as much going on down South as there is here, because they learn here how to sell drugs, although they take it back down South. Now there's as much drugs down South, almost, as there is here.
嗯，就像我说的，基本上现在都一样，因为在南方，发生的坏事和这儿差不多，因为他们学会了在这里怎么卖毒品，尽管他们又把这带回了南方。现在南方的毒品，几乎和这里一样多。
Now, Paul, you also interviewed your own mom.
现在，保罗，你也采访了你自己的妈。
Yeah.
是的。
OK, let's hear that.
好吧，我们听听那个。
What is your name?
你叫什么名字？
Linda Johnson.
琳达·约翰逊。
How do you feel about the building?
你对这栋楼感觉如何？
Well, I think the building is kind of nice. There's just too many rowdy kids.
嗯，我觉得这栋楼还不错。只是太吵闹的孩子太多了。
Do you feel like it's like a small town?
你觉得它像个小镇吗？
Yes, because every damn body in here has got a damn child by somebody's man.
是的，因为这里面的每一个该死的人，都怀着某个人的孩子。
Does like, everybody know everybody?
像是每个人都认识每个人吗？
Yes, everybody [BLEEP] everybody.
是的，每个人都[哔]每个人。
Is this the way she talks all the time?
她是总是这样说话吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Now, Carlos, you're on the second floor, right?
现在，卡洛斯，你在2楼，对吧？
Right.
对。
And what's your floor like?
那你的楼层是什么样？
My floor is just plain boring, because all the people down there--
我的楼层简直无聊透顶，因为那里的人——
They're hypes. They're hypes.
他们是“嗨粉”。他们是“嗨粉”。
Yeah, I got drug addicts on the left, drug addicts on the right.
是的，我左边有吸毒者，右边有吸毒者。
You're living around a bunch of drug addicts and it's boring?
你住在一群吸毒者周围，而且很无聊？
Well, it depends on if they had their daily medication. And the real definition for a hype is a person that smokes every day but don't have no money. They're dirty, have one pair of pants, no shirt, and maybe a half a pair of shoes or something, the people that'd do anything for the drugs.
嗯，这取决于他们是否吃了每日的药。而对于一个“嗨粉”的真正定义是一个每天抽但没钱的人。他们很脏，只有一条裤子，没衬衫，可能只有半双鞋之类的，那些为了毒品什么都愿意做的人。
Now we see hypes coming up the street [UNINTELLIGIBLE] some rocks.
现在我们看到“嗨粉”顺着街上来[无法辨认]一些毒品石。
Have you got some work, brother man?
你有活儿吗，伙计？
No sir.
没有，先生。
Let me just ask you to explain what work is?
让我问一下你解释一下什么叫“活儿”？
It's the drug, the crack cocaine.
这是毒品，快克可卡因。
You know who working?
你知道谁在干活吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Check around by the store, in the back of the building.
到商店后面，楼后面去看看。
All right, man.
好的，伙计。
What would you guys say is the biggest problem at 4120?
你们认为4120最大的问题是什么？
Biggest problem?
最大的问题？
Yeah, for you all, anyway.
是的，对你们来说，无论如何。
It's the female situation. You got to leave the building just for you to have a female, because there isn't any your age. You either date 25 and up, or they a little kid like 10 years old and down. So that's pretty much the problem.
是女性的情况。你得离开这栋楼才能有女朋友，因为没有你这个年纪的。你要么和25岁以上的约会，要么她们就是像10岁以下的小屁孩。所以这基本上就是问题所在。
Explain where the girls go.
解释一下女孩们去哪儿了。
They just leave for some reason. They'll come in and stay a little while, and then all of a sudden, their family decide it's time to move on, so they leave.
她们因为某种原因离开了。她们会进来待一会，然后突然之间，她们家人决定是时候搬走了，所以她们就离开了。
Now, do you just think it's a coincidence that girls leave? Or do you think it's one of these things where the families say, well, this building, it's kind of rough, and we don't want a girl around in this environment, we're going to take our girls out? Whereas people with boys, they just stick around.
现在，你认为女孩们离开只是巧合吗？还是你认为这是其中一件事，家庭说，嗯，这栋楼，有点乱，我们不想让女孩在这样的环境里，我们要带走我们的女孩？然而家里有男孩的，他们就留在这里。
I think that's what it is. They just want to get their daughters away from the building. If it is some girls in there that are our age, we don't want to mess with them, because of the situation that they be in, and the situation that they be causing.
我想就是这样。他们只想让他们的女儿远离这栋楼。如果里面有我们这个年纪的女孩，我们不想和她们混在一起，因为她们所处的境地，以及她们引发的境地。
You just don't feel that the girls in the building, there aren't that many who are doing that much that's positive?
你们只是觉得楼里的女孩中，没多少在做积极的事？
Right, most of them don't even go to school no more.
对，她们大多数甚至不去上学了。
Right. There's females that's dropped out that's younger than me. And I'm only 17. And they are, like, 14, 13.
对。有辍学的女孩比我小。而我才17岁。她们，像是，14岁，13岁。
If 4120 is a small town, is it one where you guys would choose to live if you had a choice?
如果4120是个小镇，你们有选择的话会住在这里吗？
It's OK to live there to me.
对我来说，住在这里还可以。
It is OK to live there, but--
住在这里还可以，但是——
I want to live in my own house, to tell you the truth, a place where I have upstairs and downstairs.
说实话，我想住在我自己的房子里，一个我有楼上和楼下的地方。
Yeah, a basement.
是的，有地下室。
Yeah, and all that.
是的，还有所有那些。
Why a basement, of all the things to name? Why a basement?
为什么是地下室，在所有要命的名词里？为什么是地下室？
You could throw a party down there, have card games.
你可以在那里开派对，打牌。
My auntie, she got a house with a basement in it, that's where she go when she don't want to be bothered with the people upstairs. She go downstairs in her basement. She got a nice little TV down there. There's some furniture down there. I'll always come back and visit the building, because that's where I grew up. It's fine there, but I wouldn't want to be there all my life.
我姨妈，她有一栋带地下室的房子，那是当她不想被楼上的人打扰时去的地方。她下到地下室。她那儿有一台不错的小电视。那儿有些家具。我总是会回来看看这栋楼，因为那是我长大的地方。那里还行，但我不想一辈子都待在那里。
If their building is, in fact, a kind of small town, then when they move away, Sanantonio, and Carlos, and Paul will probably experience what Sarah Vowell's mom experienced, what the couple I interviewed at the beginning of this program experienced when they moved away from their small towns, which is, they find they don't exactly fit into the new worlds they move to, but they no longer fit in their hometown anymore, either. As Letta Sneed, the wife of the couple at the beginning of the show said--
如果他们的楼房实际上是一种小镇，那么当他们搬走时，萨南托尼奥、卡洛斯和保罗可能会经历莎拉·沃威尔的妈妈经历过的事，我在本节目开头采访的那对夫妇搬离家乡时经历过的事，那就是，他们发现自己无法完全融入搬去的新世界，但他们也不再适合待在原来的家乡了。正如节目开头那对夫妇的妻子莱塔·斯尼德所说——
So I do feel uncomfortable with living the city life, but on the other hand it's very hard for me to conceptualize going back to a small town. And I've often wondered, I often question myself, where do I fit? And I think for the past eight years, the sad truth is, that I feel in a way, a bit homeless, like I don't fit in either world.
所以我确实对过城市生活感到不舒服，但另一方面，让我构想回到小镇也很困难。我经常想知道，我经常质疑自己，我适合哪里？我想在过去的八年里，悲哀的事实是，我觉得某种程度上，有点无家可归，就像我不适合任何一个世界。
It's like you ate from the Tree of Knowledge.
就像你吃了知识树的果子。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Well, our program was produced today Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike, Julie Snyder, and Paul Tough. Contributing editor Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, and Margie Rochlin. Production help from Christina Stephens.
好的，我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人，以及南希·厄普代克、朱莉·斯奈德和保罗·塔夫制作。特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗奇林。克里斯蒂娜·斯蒂芬斯提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who could be heard most days wandering around the office singing this song.
WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚，人们大部分时间都能听到他在办公室里徘徊唱着这首歌。
I will be a helper at home, at church, at school.
我要做个好帮手，在家里、在教堂、在学校。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。